أجنبي
لماذا ترى دائمًا الموظ طليقًا
حيث لا ينبغي أن يتم احتجازهم على
الأريكة في مستشفى ألاسكا
أو مضغ الفشار داخل
صالة السينما هذه المرة هيا أيها العجل الصغير
اذهب إلى هناك، لقد كان عجلًا غير قادر على
متابعة عجله  أم فوق حاجز طريق سريع
لا تستطيع أو لا تريد، ما الذي تعتقد أنه
لا يمكن أن يبدو ربلة الساق جيدًا منذ حوالي
أسبوع، قام سائق الشاحنة رودني بيير بتصوير
المشهد أثناء اللعب في برينس جورج
كولومبيا البريطانية في كندا،
ظلت الأم تقفز فوق  حاجز كما
لو أنها تظهر لطفلها ما يجب فعله ولكن
بغض النظر عن عدد المرات التي أظهرت فيها ذلك
بأي حال من الأحوال ولكن على الأقل لم
ينتهي الأمر بهذين الاثنين مثل روكي وبولوينكل
[تصفيق]
توقف السامري الصالح للمساعدة ولكن
الأم لم تفعل ذلك  أقدر ذلك، سوف
تحصل على وشم الأحمق اللعين على الرجل الذي
خرج من سيارته، ما هي استراتيجيته،
لا أعرف، يبدو أنه كان
سيلتقط العجل ويرفعه فوق،
ليس من غير المألوف أن يصطدم الموظ
بالمركبات
في النهاية، اختارت الأم والعجل أن يسلكا
منحدر الخروج باتجاه Walmart، وإذا
كنت تميل إلى إعطاء حيوان الموظ الصغير
مصعدًا أفضل لتستمتع بـ
Genie Mouse CNN New York